después de casi dos décadas de combate
las tropas estadounidenses serán
retiradas de afganistán es hora de poner
fin a la guerra más larga de eeuu es
hora de que las tropas estadounidenses
regresen a casa bailén dice que lo harán
antes del vigésimo aniversario de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre quienes
fuimos a afganistán debido a un terrible
ataque que ocurrió hace 20 años
eso no puede explicar por qué deberíamos
permanecer allí en 2021
en lugar de volver a la guerra con los
talibanes tenemos que centrarnos en los
desafíos que tenemos por delante tenemos
que rastrear e interrumpir las redes y
operaciones terroristas que se han
extendido mucho más allá de afganistán
desde el 11 de septiembre la decisión no
es inesperada el predecesor de bailén
donald trump también se había
comprometido a retirar a los 2500
soldados norteamericanos restantes en el
país antes del primero de mayo los
observadores temen que la retirada pueda
conducir al colapso de las fuerzas de
seguridad locales sumergiendo a
afganistán en una guerra civil que
involucra a los talibanes y otras
facciones pero el presidente afgano a
sur afgano insistió en que sus fuerzas
armadas son totalmente capaces de
defender al país dijo que trabajará con
eeuu para garantizar una transición sin
problemas ese sentimiento fue compartido
por la otan la alianza acordó retirar
sus aproximadamente siete mil soldados
no estadounidenses
y este no es el final de nuestra
relación granja ni stan sino el comienzo
de un nuevo capítulo los aliados y
socios de la otan seguirán apoyando al
pueblo afgano washington dice que ahora
elaborará un plan coordinado con sus
aliados de la otan que comenzará a
principios de mayo y finalizará a
principios de septiembre